If you have assertions in your code, not only can you detect errors much more easily
but you can also test your code much more thoroughly.
In particular, you can separate two things. A test consists of two parts.
First we need to generate on execution and second we need to check the outcome.
With assertions in your code, checking the results is already done
so we can focus on generating the tests.
Let me illustrate with a very, very simple example.
The idea is that we're going to take a square root function with assertions integrated
and just use random testing to test it.
Here's a very, very simple implementation of the square root function.
We simply invert the built-in Python square root function from the math module,
and we have set up appropriate assertions to check for the precondition and for the post condition
Now for the test driver, I have set up a loop with 1000 iterations
and we generate random numbers in the range of 0 to 9,999.99.
This is random with random function which returned a value between 0 and 1.
This is the floating point number and it comes from the random module
and then when we feed this random number into a square root function turning assuming the result in z
Note that we don't do any assertions down here
because the assertions up here have already take care of everything.
When all test are successful, we print out done.
So this is our test and the question is, what's going to happen?
Is it the program terminates gracefully, output is done, all test are fast.
Is it that the square root precondition fail? Is it that the square root post condition fails?
Or thinking of Python, do we see something completely different. Over to you.